key bonjour à tous imaginez que vous
deviez recruter quelqu'un pour votre
entreprise
que ce soit pour la com ou pour le
service haïti comment est ce que vous y
prendriez vous allé recueillir des cv
puis les analyser et puis sur base de
l'analyse faire passer des interviews
alors c'est une interview ce sera
l'occasion de vérifier si les candidats
sont compétents et puis aussi de
vérifier s'ils ont un projet s'ils ont
une vision qui correspond à celle que
vous que vous pensez nécessaires pour
votre entreprise
ce qui est certain en tout les cas c'est
que vous n'allez pas simplement prendre
les cv
regardez les photos et vous dire
celui-là il a vraiment une bonne tête
celle là elle a une chouette chemise
allez c'est parti je langage la question
je voudrais poser dès lors c'est
pourquoi n'effectuons nous pas ce même
travail lorsque nous élisons le
mandataire politique
après tout le rôle qu'il jouait
essentiel dans nos vies les politiques
qu'ils mènent ont un impact à la fois
sur la qualité de l'éducation scolaire
la hauteur des impôts la qualité des
routes des transports en commun de la
politique environnementale etc
alors il ya énormément d'études qui
s'intéresse justement au désintérêt au
désenchantement qu'on beaucoup de
citoyens par rapport au monde politique
et par rapport aux élections alors je
vais peut-être vous décevoir mais c'est
passé cause que je vais vous présenter
aujourd'hui ce que je vais vous
présenter aujourd'hui c'est comme avec
le projet make her own chase
on a essayé de rapprocher un petit peu
les citoyens et les candidats aux
élections alors à l'origine du projet
make her own choses me choquent pour les
intimes il y a le fameux et tant attendu
rer bruxellois le réseau express
régional qui devait permettre d'accéder
plus rapidement à bruxelles alors vous
le dis d'emblée
heureusement notre histoire se termine
mieux que la sienne alors en avril 2017
alors que j'écoutais la radio d'une
oreille en prenant mon petit déjeuner
j'ai entendu le ministre président de la
région bruxelles capitale
annoncée entre autres choses le x6m
report de la date d'achèvement du rer là
j'étais un peu déçu et je me suis dit
c'est quand même dingue et travaux ont
commencé en 2004 le monde politique nous
avait annoncé une mise en service en
2012 puis ce fut 2015 puis 2019-2020 tu
es maintenant 2025 plus de vingt ans
plus tard
et si ça se trouve c'est ce même
mandataires politiques qui initialement
et notamment dans le cadre de ces
campagnes électorales avait promis un
rer opérationnelle en 2012 puis 2015
2019 là j'ai commencé à me poser pas mal
de questions et notamment comment
peut-on évaluer le travail qui est
effectué par nos mandataires politiques
alors que très souvent on vote pour eux
mais sans connaître leur programme
qu'est ce que c'est finalement
l'élection la campagne électorale est-ce
que ça se limite à des affiches donc des
visages toujours plus grand toujours
plus nombreux dans les rues et puis des
tracts qui s'entassent dans les boîtes
aux lettres et qui avons le termine le
plus souvent dans la poubelle avant
d'avoir été lus ou en tout cas avant
qu'ils étaient comparés entre eux alors
si ça se limite à ça je pense qu'on
ferait mieux de parler d'une campagne de
pub que d'une campagne électorale et
alors on devrait accepter l'idée que on
choisit nos mandataires politiques comme
on choisit du savon à lessive et au
supermarché c'est à dire
inconsciemment au hasard alors
personnellement à l'époque je dois avec
j'avais beaucoup de difficulté tout
simplement à me rappeler pour qui
j'avais voté alors son programme ça j'en
suis certain je n'avais jamais pris
connaissance et j'ai commencé à
interroger mes proches pour voir si
finalement le problème n'était pas de
mon côté j'ai commencé par mon petit
frère sacha qui est un très jeune
juriste mais très talentueux et qui m'a
répondu qu'il avait voté comme moi du
coup ça m'a pas mener très loin j'ai
continué à poser des questions à mes
proches
est ce que tu te souviens pour quitte à
voter en 2012 est ce qu'il a été élu
est-ce que tu avais pris connaissance de
son programme est assez rapidement je me
suis rendu compte que mon frère et moi
n'étions pas des cas isolés
bonjour ne donne pas ce que vous savez
pour qui vous allez voter dimanche
non même pas encore d'idée vous allez
faire comment pour vous faire une idée
je sais pas c'est ma première année
est ce que tu sais déjà pour qui je vais
voter dimanche pas du tout je pense que
je vais voter m j'ai une info moi je
veux juste aller dimanche votée puis sur
le sol maman je vais trouver ce qui me
plaît le plus quoi un feeling si michael
puis non ben on a plein de tracts sont
mis dans les boîtes à lettres
ouais c'est ça alors ce qui m'a
interpellé c'est que finalement on vit
dans des démocraties qui reste
principalement représentative à l'heure
actuelle et dans cette démocratie s'il
ya un moment pendant lequel on peut
vraiment s'exprimer par rapport au
travail qui est effectué par nos
mandataires politiques
c'est lorsque nous votons or pour
beaucoup d'entre nous et moi y compris
il était devenu habituel de voter pour
des visages des personnes dont on a
vaguement entendu parler ou carrément au
pif et pas pour des programmes des
mesures concrètes
on voudrait voir réaliser dans notre
commune dans notre région dans notre
pays alors face à tous ces constats on
s'est dit il faudrait qu'on essaye de
faire quelque chose pour redonner du
sens en tout cas redonné un peu plus de
sens à l'élection pour retisser du lien
entre les candidats et les électeurs
alors que quelque chose est assez
rapidement devenu un projet de
plateforme en ligne qui devait permettre
aux soixante mille candidats aux
dernières élections communales de se
présenter mais aussi de présenter leur
programme est alors aux citoyens de
comparer ces programmes plus facilement
et notamment avec des comparaisons par
thématique alors le nous donc
initialement mon petit frère sacha mon
épouse mode qui est professeur en
promotion sociale et moi qui était alors
avocat est devenue une asbl la sbl make
her own chose qu'à lancer une campagne
de crohn funding et puis qui a engagé
une agence de web développement alors on
a aussi élargi l'équipe jusqu'à être une
quinzaine de bénévoles jeunes
responsables francophones et flamands et
puis on a eu l'aide d'une cinquantaine
d'ambassadeurs qui étaient répartis un
peu partout en belgique alors en avril
la plateforme a été mise en ligne et
pour ceux qui
n'ont pas eu l'occasion de l'utiliser il
suffisait de taper le code postal d'une
des 589 communes belges pour voir
s'afficher les candidats qui s'étaient
inscrits dans cette commune la et alors
vous pouviez consulter leurs mesures
phares et puis comparer facilement les
programmes des listes et notamment par
thématique culture sport travaux publics
alors en tant que citoyen vous pouviez
aussi poster des propositions citoyennes
ce qui a pas mal marché d'ailleurs
propositions par rapport auxquelles les
candidats étaient alors invités à se
positionner
alors vous pouvez vous demander
maintenant qu'est ce que ça a donné
finalement cette plate forme et je vais
me permettre de parler chiffres pendant
quelques secondes
on a eu huit cent cinquante candidats
qui se sont inscrits
cinquante mille citoyens qui se sont
rendus sur la plateforme pour s'informer
avant d'aller voter
trois cent mille pages vues et ça pour
2/3 je dirais le week end des élections
donc le samedi et le dimanche du 14
octobre
alors ces résultats sont de notre point
de vue mitigé parce que d'un côté on a
ce qu'on considère être une très
important de demandes d'informations de
la part des citoyens qui veulent avoir
une une information relative au
programme qui soit plus accessible plus
intelligible mais de l'autre côté on a
l'impression qu'on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés pour répondre à cette
demande
et pourquoi tout d'abord parce que
l'information qu'on a pu proposer était
incomplète 850 candidats inscrits sur
soixante mille candidats ça reste
marginal comme taux de participation
évidemment tous les candidats n'étaient
pas au courant de l'existence de cette
nouvelle plateforme et puis à tous des
candidats qui font pas vraiment campagne
aussi met alors à côté de ça on a eu on
a été confronté à un deuxième écueil qui
est le caractère en fait peu concrets de
l'information qui étaient présentes sur
la plateforme
alors mon but est pas du tout de jeter
la pierre sur les candidats qui
s'étaient inscrits mais simplement le
fait est qu'on a reçu beaucoup de
messages de citoyens qui nous ont dit
que même en utilisant la plateforme
ils étaient finalement assez difficile
de faire un choix parce que beaucoup de
candidats proposent plus ou moins les
mêmes choses et très souvent dans des
termes assez vague
c'est à dire une commune plus verte une
commune plus c'est une commune avec des
finances publiques plus saines une
commune avec des trottoirs qui sont
venus nettoyer et c'est alors on a un
peu regardés on a constaté
qu'effectivement c'était le cas et que
ça correspondait pas à ce qu'on voulait
à la base c'est à dire avoir des projets
concrets des données chiffrées des
engagements par rapport auquel il est
possible d'évaluer si oui ou non ils ont
été réalisés et à ce niveau là on a
vraiment eu l'impression d'être
confronté à une réticence de la part des
candidats
par exemple il ya certains partis qui
n'envisage pas de laisser leur candidat
m sur une plateforme contrôlé par un
tiers
justement des engagements concrets des
données chiffrées et s'est alors je
donne juste un petit exemple
accrochez vous bien à votre siège on a
même reçu des demandes de certains
candidats qui voulait s'assurer que
après le 14 octobre
il serait bien possible d'effacer leur
programme bon on l'a fait mais je veux
dire on n'a pas trop compris la logique
alors vous pouvez un peu imaginer notre
frustration lorsque d'un côté on a ce
genre de demandes de la part de certains
candidats est alors de l'autre côté
plein de messages de citoyens qui nous
demandent pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya pas
plus de candidats inscrits dans ma
commune pourquoi telle liste n'a pas
complété son programme du coup je peux
pas la comparer avec le programme de
telle autre liste donc en termes de
résultats
en dehors de tout ce que nous on a
appris je dirais que la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'il ya effectivement des
milliers de citoyens des milliers de
jeunes qui souhaitent s'informer qui
souhaitent comparer les programmes des
candidats avant d'aller voter et je me
permets une toute petite parenthèse
lorsqu'il y a des milliers de jeunes
aussi qui descendent dans les rues
régulièrement pour réclamer une
politique environnementale qui soit à la
hauteur de l'enjeu climatique
c'est aussi des jeunes qui veulent jouer
leur rôle de citoyen de façon active et
responsable et je pense que c'est la
même chose avec les élections il ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui veulent pas
spécialement voter comme leurs parents
et c'est pour ces jeunes là aussi qu'on
a lancé la plateforme york
alors j'espère que vous vous demandez
maintenant qu'est-ce que l'équipe myope
nous prend nous réserve pour les
prochaines élections et
j'ai à dire qu'on a beaucoup réfléchi
après notre expérience au niveau des
communales on s'est dit on mais comment
est ce qu'on peut faire pour donner une
information qui soit plus pertinente
après tout notre projet c'est c'est un
projet qui est porté par une asbl c'est
un projet citoyen comment est ce qu'on
peut faire pour que notre plateforme ce
soit plus qu'un simple service de com
gratuit pour les candidats une simple
vitrine pour les candidats qui
promettent les plus belles choses alors
on a d'abord pensé lancer une plateforme
qui aurait permis aux candidats de
répondre à des questions posées par les
citoyens et sous forme de vidéo mais le
projet n'a pas pu aboutir tout
simplement parce qu'on avait plus de
sous mais aussi parce qu'on a on n'avait
pas le temps de développer cette
plateforme là comme on le voulait avant
l'échéance des prochaines élections
et du coup c'est on s'est demandé aux
quais le but de notre aise belle ces
deux décès de réduire un peu l'écart
entre les candidats et les électeurs
et s'il ya bien un niveau qu'elle
s'était carla est particulièrement fort
ressenti c'est au niveau européen alors
l'impact des politiques européennes est
très important que ce soit les traités
de libre échange qui sont négociés par
la commission les normes budgétaires
européennes
les la gestion des crises migratoires
financière la gestion des données
personnelles
bref la liste est très longue et les
politiques eux l'ont très bien compris
combien de fois n'avez vous pas entendu
un homme ou une femme politique reporter
la responsabilité d'un problème sur
l'union européenne ou mais non vous
n'avez pas compris ça ça doit être réglé
par une directive en fait ok mais du
coup ci c'est au niveau européen que
tant de choses peuvent être solutionnés
on propose de redoubler d'attention
lorsque nous irons voter pour les
membres du parlement européen
et pour ça on va vous aider est ce qu'on
va faire c'est sillonné la belgique pour
organiser des rencontres entre citoyens
et candidats
alors concrètement l'idée est de
proposer à toutes les listes d'aller
chercher un de leurs candidats
donc on ira chercher le candidat en
question l'embarras dans la camionnette
nioc là il aurait une petite interview
devra répondre à une série de questions
ce sera filmé pour faire des vidéos
et surtout on va l'amener dans des lieux
publics où auront lieu ces rencontres
citoyennes qui auront été organisées
évidemment au préalable et là ce sera
l'occasion pour le candidat de présenter
son programme par rapport à quelques
thématiques
mais surtout ce sera l'occasion pour les
citoyens de questionner le candidat de
lui faire des propositions de deux de
solliciter son avis par rapport à
certains problèmes
donc le problème le l'idée c'est
vraiment laid c'est d'un tout petit peu
de faire redescendre la politique
européenne dans la rue dans les lieux
publics dans les écoles dans les cafés
alors je voudrais conclure en disant une
chose je pense qu'on l'a bien compris ce
soir
nos sociétés sont confrontées à des
défis qui sont gigantesques et les
décisions qui seront prises et notamment
par les hommes politiques que nous le
voulions ou non seront décisives
alors on voudrait à juste titre que nos
hommes et nos femmes politiques soient à
la hauteur de ces enjeux
mais n'oublions pas une chose c'est que
en principe c'est nous qui les
choisissons nos dirigeants et nous
devons aussi prendre nos responsabilités
et prendre ses responsabilités en tant
que citoyen en tant qu'électeur cela
passe par se renseigner par rapport aux
programmes des candidats par rapport au
travail des mandataires politiques
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont voté qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont déposé comme projet de loi
évidemment ça demande du travail mais
c'est ce travail qui va donner le sens
finalement à cette notion de démocratie
je vous remercie beaucoup pour votre
attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]